thursday edition hiatus style pft live
pftpm july 8 is the date in case you're
wondering although you don't have to
wonder anymore it's on your phone as is
everything else that you ever need
here's what you need to know about the
national football league while we get
closer and closer to the start of
training camp news continues to emerge
thanks in part
to kyle shanahan the 49ers head coach
who said not that long ago in a podcast
with michael irvin when talking about
the chances of rookie quarterback trey
lance winning the starting job in san
francisco right away that he didn't want
to
create
something that would allow me
to generate an annoying headline when he
pointed out that in theory yes trey
lance could end up being the starter
so in a more recent podcast
with sean mcvay and peter shreger flying
coach is the name of the podcast
shanahan
who for some reason agreed to step into
the lion's den
said all sorts of things that first
and let me just
raise a broad question here here's what
i would ask kyle if i had a chance to
talk to him one-on-one and i've spoken
to him before he's good friends with
chris i like kyle i've said before i'm
on the record he's got the potential to
be
a bill belichick he is a genius when it
comes to football specifically offensive
football and but for rash of injuries
last year possibly would have been back
in the super bowl could be back this
year could be in the annual conversation
and ultimately could have as many rings
as belichick does
i believe that
of him as it relates to his coaching
abilities however
and and i'm
i'm hesitant to say this
because it cuts against
my business interests
he needs to stop talking
take a page from bill belichick and zip
it
don't bear your soul and i want to know
the back story here and maybe i'll try
to find it out
how did they get him to do this was this
just an ego thing he and mcveigh have
this rivalry that you know i'm not going
to act like it's a robber i'm not going
to say no to you because then if i say
no
i'm i you know i i'm yeah i don't have
the guts to come talk to yeah i got the
guts to talk to you i'll talk to i'll
talk to one of my top rivals young coach
younger than me
guy who's taken his team to the super
bowl one year before i took my team to
the super bowl guy whose team has
upgraded this year and is one of the
favorites in the nfc while my team is
trying to to get its sea legs again
yeah i'll do it i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna shy away from
it he said plenty of things
and maybe there's a strategy there that
i'm not capable
of grasping but again i look at
belichick belichick would have never
done
a podcast like that would have never
been so candid about so many different
topics
including most importantly and i'm not
going to get into the other ones because
the uh hey thanks mcveigh and schreger
for giving us something to write about
and talk about in the middle of july but
what shanahan had to say about matthew
stafford it became clear
that the 49ers wanted matthew stafford
they tried to get in the mix
for a stafford trade but they got
involved too late ship had sailed
and and frankly
i don't think any of it would have
mattered i think it was
a a deal that was brokered between
lesney the gm of the rams and brad
holmes the gm of the lions who had been
an executive with the rams
the experience with the rams got him the
job
the best way
to
to
hide the debacle that was the jared goff
contract was to put him in the matthew
stafford trade package
in lieu of trading jared goff to some
other team and giving that team a first
round pick to take jared goff that's
what they otherwise would have had to do
to get rid of jared goff if they were
going to upgrade it quarterback this was
perfect this was the the best way and
maybe the only way the rams could have
pulled it off getting a new quarterback
while also getting rid of the jared goff
contract without it being so conspicuous
that they got rid of the jared goff
contract by giving up a first round pick
so i don't think anything was going to
disrupt that deal
i think that's the unvarnished truth
but when shanahan says yeah we
called
stafford's agent tom condon and it was
too late
okay
so what quarterbacks didn't the 49ers
want this off season as an upgrade over
jimmy garoppolo
they wanted matthew stafford
there's a belief they wanted sam darnold
they wanted aaron rodgers that was the
news that lit the fuse on the entire
aaron rodgers explosion of the past
couple of months it wasn't the report
from espn that rogers isn't happy it was
the report from paul allen of kfan that
the 49ers had tried the night before the
draft
to trade for aaron rodgers
and then
many in league circles believe
believe
and may be right that when the 49ers
traded from 12 to 3 ultimately investing
three first-round picks and a
third-round pick in one player
that shanahan wanted mac jones
and was eventually
talked out of it and or led to the point
where he made the decision on his own
that he wanted trey lance instead of
mack jones
so how many quarterbacks other than
jimmy garoppolo
did you want kyle
for 2021 how many it may be easier to
list the guys he didn't want than the
guys that he did want we've got stafford
we've got darnold we've got rogers we've
got mac jones ultimately trey lance
and here's what's so strange about it
and this is why i've spent the time to
kind of make this point the way that i'd
like to
garoppolo's still the starting
quarterback of the san francisco 49ers
what the hell is wrong with this picture
he wanted stafford he wanted this guy he
wanted that guy and and as of right now
if they had to play a game today and of
course they don't garoppolo would be the
starter and maybe lance will win the job
during camp but i think back to
comments from 49er ceo jed york
right after the draft he did a podcast
with matt mayoko of nbc sports bay area
the idea that if they keep garoppolo for
the next two years while they develop
trey lance that's 50 million dollars
invested in
the development of lance because that's
50 million that jimmy garoppolo will
make over the next two years so
look
i i continue to believe
that the 49ers
have allowed themselves to freak out
in the aftermath of
not evaluating patrick mahomes not
wanting tom brady when brady wanted to
play for the 49ers
let's rewind to 2020. brady becomes a
free agent or he's eventually going to
become a free agent and the patriots
didn't really mind that multiple teams
were tampering with tom brady brady
makes it known to the 49ers he wants to
come home he wants to play for the team
he grew up rooting for
a super bowl ready team because they'd
just been to the super bowl and but for
jimmy garoppolo not being able to hit an
open
emanuel sanders he wasn't quite wide as
open as bruce erins would say but he was
open championship throw second straight
year a championship throw isn't made
first by goff now by garoppolo
brady would have made that throw
he didn't want brady they decided to
stick with jimmy garoppolo
i just think
watching mahomes versus brady in the
super bowl was in my view
the icing on the cake the cherry on top
of the icing on the cake the dollop of
whipped cream on top of the cherry on
top of the icing on top of the cake that
they had to get rid of jimmy garoppolo
they had to move on from jimmy garoppolo
and here we are after all of those
machinations after all of those guys
that kyle shanahan was interested in
getting
garoppolo is still
the starting quarterback of the san
francisco 49ers and could be for all
of the
2021 season and possibly beyond
speaking of tom brady he made some news
a couple of weeks ago time gets kind of
twisted and bent and you know during
this period where
my usual routine is out the window
although we've developed a routine with
the hiatus pft live
tom brady was on the shop uninterrupted
hbo
and
he made the comment that that hbo wisely
used to promote the show
that tom brady
when he was looking for a team late in
the process there was a team that said
they're not interested and he said
you're sticking with that mother bleeper
and he didn't elaborate on the team or
said mother bleeper
and so that sparked days of trying to
figure out who it was all sorts of
different theories out there from ryan
fitzpatrick to ryan tannehill to mitch
trubisky to derek carr and there are
people in the league and we wrote this
at pft to the chagrin of at least one
person who covers the raiders
we wrote based upon the beliefs of
people in the league
people who are working for teams and who
are privy to the conversations that
brady was referring to derek carr well
derek carr appearing with brother from
another on wednesday at lake tahoe where
the american century celebrity
championship happens this weekend
carr said he's not the person to whom
brady was referring he wouldn't name the
source good source he's told it wasn't
brady now
other than it being brady himself i
don't know that i'd trust any other
source because any other source
especially if it's a raiders source
they're not going to tell
carr yeah you know what we did make a
late run at tom brady
and uh he he he was referring to you
yeah we've we've connected the dots here
and yeah yeah you're the guy you're the
guy
you're the mother bleeper with whom we
decided to stick they're not going to
tell him that gruden's not going to tell
him that
and even if he had a direct conversation
with tom brady is brady going to come
out and say it i don't think and one of
the other things brady said during that
show 90 of the stuff he says isn't true
anyway why would he tell derek carr that
he was the guy there's a chance
theoretically the brady
led buccaneers and the car led raiders
meeting super bowl 56 i think it's very
slim because i don't think the raiders
can stack up to the best teams in the
afc but why give carr extra motivation
in the event
that it's carr versus brady in super
bowl 56 so brady wouldn't tell him the
truth brady would whoever it is
if that guy asked tom brady point blank
am i the guy you were talking about
brady's going to say it wasn't you
and i guarantee you
that when training camp starts and tom
brady has asked that question first of
all i don't think he's going to be asked
that question second of all when he's
asked that question he's not going to
answer it he's going to talk for 10
minutes about whatever he wants to talk
about and then the person who asked the
question will have forgotten what the
question was so bottom line i ain't
buying it hey if derek believes it fun
if that's what he needs to think to go
forward with his career fine
but i don't believe it
i don't believe that he wasn't the guy
because people in the league believe he
was the guy so someone was the guy and
we probably will never find out who it
was
a lot of dwelling on the past going on
between the 49ers and brady and thinking
about what may have been doug peterson
former coach of the eagles has said
recently he's not going to dwell on his
past with the philadelphia eagles he's
thinking about the future he also said
recently that he wants to coach again
and i'm fascinated by
whether or not he's going to be one of
the guys whose name makes it into the
rotation of usual suspects when the time
comes to put together the coaching
candidates for the 2022 cycle and it'll
be here before we know it right after
the season ends there will be teams that
fire their coaches it happens every year
it's up to eight teams usually
and we hear the hot assistance that
percolates all year long
maybe a college coach in the event that
the jaguars end up being pretty good
this year copycat league hey let's go
get a college coach guy who's never
coached in the nfl at work for the
jaguars
able to work for us
and then the other alternative is the
recycled coach the fired coach
well there aren't a lot of fired coaches
out there
who have super bowl ranks
i mean doug peterson won the super bowl
in his
second season as head coach of the
philadelphia eagles that's got to count
for something
will he be regarded as a top candidate
how much blame
is going to land on him
for the disintegration
of a super bowl team i mean
think about the past three seasons in
philly 18 19 20.
has there been a super bowl champion
that has fallen apart faster
than
the eagles did maybe the cowboys after
super bowl 30
but it wasn't the same coach they moved
on from barry switzer to dave campo at
some point i believe during that three
year cycle afterward
but to to have doug peterson come in
team gets put together climbs at the top
of the mountain grabs the flag wins the
championship and falls apart like that
how much blame goes to him how much
blame goes to ownership how much blame
goes to gm harry roseman how much blame
goes to someone else i don't know but
that's one of the things that any team
that is thinking about making a change
after this season and i guarantee you
there are already owners out there
who are at least pondering the
possibility depending upon how the
season goes and if it starts
poorly for those teams they'll start
looking around and lining up the
candidates you got to figure out
how much blame
ends up
at the feet of doug peterson and will it
be so much blame
that he doesn't get his name into the
conversation for guys who get that
second chance the credentials the super
bowl win
the mere fact that he won a super bowl
should be enough
to get him a second chance we'll see if
it does somebody asked a question
earlier this week about whether lamar
jackson in his negotiations directly
with ravens gm eric decosta may emerge
with a deal that pays him a percentage
of the salary cap it dawned on me
earlier today because my my position
generally is
teams don't want to do it the league
doesn't want the teams to do it
and the guy in best position to do it
is a guy who has all the leverage who's
on the brink of free agency a dak
prescott type of a guy a kirk cousins
type of a guy someone who's dealing with
a team that has no other real options
but to say fine
we will come up with a structure that
guarantees that your cap number will be
x percent of the total amount we have
available
it occurred to me this morning
maybe josh allen's the right guy for it
now i don't know that the bills give him
a structure like that after only three
years
but josh allen seems like a guy who
number one really wants to stay in
buffalo and number two
would be willing to do a deal
that fairly ensures
that
the bills will have
the cash and cap space available to keep
a competitive team around him and
there's no device like that
other than
the
guarantee of a percentage of the cap
whatever the cap is i am only going to
count
15 16 17 and it'll never be a round
number if it ever happens and i hope it
does happen
it'll be
17.2347 it'll be like pie it'll be
something that is ridiculously
negotiated and specific to make it look
like there was some grand formula at
play and maybe there was maybe it'll be
the result of an analysis
conducted by the analytics department of
every major quarterback contract for the
past 30 years and what percentage of the
cap that quarterback accounted for each
year with statistical averages and and a
final number they'll hit the button and
the number's going to be spat out and
that's the magic number whatever it is
however they get there
that that's the fair way to do it i
don't know why the teams don't want to
do it
but that's the fair way to do it now
teams will say we want cost certainty
but you never have cost certainty when
the salary cap changes every year based
on how much revenue you have
so
hey
i suspect the bills are tempted to offer
josh allen the same deal patrick mahomes
got because it's a it's a player
friendly team friendly win-win
half a billion dollar deal but you got
to commit for 12 years to get there
i think alan and his representatives
should look at that and say no i'm
willing to work with you i'm willing to
make sure you've got more than 80 cents
on every dollar to spend on other
players and i'm willing to tie my cap
percentage to historically what great
quarterbacks have gotten
super bowl winning quarterbacks have
gotten put tom brady in the formula as
well let's do a full average from brady
doing team friendly deals all the way up
to peyton manning whose attitude was
bleep you pay me it's my job to get paid
as much as i can it's your job to manage
the cap come up with that number
whatever it is
and that's josh allen's
maximum salary guaranteed for the next x
number of years whatever the cap is that
percent is what he's going to get
i think it makes a lot of sense
probably means it'll never happen
but i think josh allen may be the one to
do it and i think josh allen can make a
compelling case for it and i've yet to
hear a compelling case from anyone on
the team side other than frankly
the management council doesn't want us
to do it which of course is collusion
but good luck proven collusion
in an arbitration setting all right
let's answer some questions before we
wrap this up
i have not pre-screened these
so
um
let's see what we have here i'll screen
them as i go pfdp and posse won't we
know which players have been vaccinated
once camps open up because it'll be
obvious who's wearing masks getting
tested daily restricted eating etc yes
it will be and i've asked the league in
the past will there be transparency
about who has been and who hasn't been
vaccinated because even though it's not
going to be a major factor
in the betting habits
of the americans who are by the millions
legally betting on
football games but it's a factor
if if i have to account for the slim
possibility that unvaccinated starting
quarterback as of sunday morning is
going to be swabbed they're going to do
that mesa test which is an on-site pcr
test highly reliable
and they they determine he's positive
that morning and that's it he's done he
can't play
well if the guy's vaccinated you don't
have to worry about that vaccinated
players are only tested once every two
weeks they're not going to be tested on
game days that risk if you're vaccinated
of finding out saturday or sunday
because i guarantee you the one test
every two weeks isn't happening the day
before the day of a game
for vaccinated player it's not a risk at
all it's not a reality at all for
unvaccinated players it is
so i think we need to know
and and
the question is appropriate because
we'll figure it out
that's going to be part of the reporting
that's done
if players aren't going to say whether
or not they've been vaccinated
we'll know who's wearing a mask
and there will be people in the media
who try to shout down the reporting it's
none of our business it is our business
because we need to know who's available
who's not available we need to know
which guys may suddenly be unavailable
on the day of a game it's that simple
health of players has always been an
open book and this is no different and
and and you can't just all of a sudden
say it's nobody's business simply
because
it deals with a politically charged
issue that has caused folks to to take
very strong positions on either side of
it all right
let's see what else we have here
at jr the boss man the nba is a virtual
lock to expand to las vegas and seattle
what markets are in the conversation as
it pertains to potential nfl expansion
well i'll say this jr the boss man the
conversation about potential nfl
expansion hasn't happened yet i think
the nfl is looking at this in a linear
fashion first they got to 17 games next
they'll get to 18 games
they won't be able to increase the
inventory of total games beyond 18. so
the only way to increase the inventory
of total games
after you get to an 18 game season is to
expand the number of teams more teams
more games
i would suspect
that cities that have successfully
hosted nfl teams in the past would be in
the mix now the lawsuit filed by st
louis against the nfl set to go to trial
by the way
uh
right about the time the super bowl
happens in la where the rams moved i
think st louis at some point would
potentially be in play and maybe a
settlement would include some sort of
favored nation status for st louis in
the event that there's expansion in the
future that's part of the deal that
averted litigation when the browns left
cleveland back in 1995. i'd say san
diego to the extent that someone's going
to build a stadium there without
taxpayer dollars
i would say and and this whole chicago
arlington heights stadium thing has gone
from
not even a whisper to a roar in just a
few weeks
the bears are going to build their own
stadium state-of-the-art maximum revenue
streams number three market
in the nation the number one market has
two teams the number two market has two
teams
i think chicago
would be a potential site either for
relocation or expansion and also london
al michaels
said 10 years ago
when the league goes back to los angeles
it will be two teams not one i think
there's room for two teams in london and
i think if the nfl over does go to
london it will be two teams whether it's
expansion or whether it's an expansion
team and
a current team maybe a current team that
plays in london
every single year
hey and i i know folks in jacksonville
you're not happy to hear that but i'm
not the one who's decided that the
jaguars are going to play a home game in
london every year
justin ladd
otherwise known as on twitter at dynasty
mad
what dominos do you anticipate falling
before camp after camp trade deadline if
any who's on the roster bubble is a cap
casualty that's a very broad question we
could do a whole show on that but i will
say this
there will be
cap casualties as we get closer there
are look this isn't
this is captain obvious stuff but i
think this year more than any with the
cap net 25 million lower per team than
it would have been but for the pandemic
once
coaches see what young cheap players can
do
at training camp practices
and during preseason games
as we get closer to the start of the
season i think it will be more common
than usual that a veteran who is making
six seven eight million dollars is going
to have that awkward conversation where
the team says
yeah we we can't
we can't pay you that much this year we
want you to take half we want you to
take 25 whatever the number is
because when that conversation happens a
couple of weeks before the start of the
season
it's not like the guy has many options
the depth charts are set for most other
teams no one's going to pivot and say oh
we can get this guy
for
x dollars more than what his team is
willing to pay him now
that was the lawyer malloy thing from
back in 2003. remember that
patriots squeezed him to take less right
before the start of the season he said
no he shopped
the market even though that's tampering
for the teams to engage it happens all
the time he admitted it he admitted that
there was tampering ended up in buffalo
and uh got more in buffalo than what the
patriots were willing to pay him on a
reduced contract that's the way the game
is played and i think this year we'll
see it more than usual
let's see what else we have here
jr the boss man coming through with
another question at what point do you
believe the titans will redo julio jones
contract there was a belief in league
circles that julio jones may want a new
deal on the way in
to his new team
i think the more realistic
outcome here is julio jones
after reestablishing himself in 2021 as
one of the premier receivers in the nfl
will want to be paid on the back end
next year by the titans and that's going
to create some awkwardness for the
titans because aj brown
their great receiver from mississippi
second round pick in 2019 becomes
eligible for a new contract after this
season they could have both aj brown and
julio jones clamoring for new contracts
while still under contract after this
season good problem to have if it gets
to the point where both guys think they
deserve top end money but still a
problem because you got to figure out
which one you're going to pay are you
going to keep both what are you going to
do can you can you work this out
financially with that much money
invested in two players who play the
same position
what else do we have here
matt naylor 1986 how much do the lions
need to be considered at least
contenders within the nfc north i look i
i like what the lions are doing
60 years of futility the old school
approach the kneecap biting mindset
rough and tumble
i like it
we'll see what the limits are
of it we'll see if players are going to
be playing through the whistle and
potentially angering
their colleagues on other teams there's
a greater sense of brotherhood among nfl
teams than ever before especially given
the sensitivity to health and safety we
don't see the dirty players like we used
to and when we do they get called out
aggressively
by by players on other teams
uh we'll see
look hey the nfc is not nearly as top
heavy as the afc so there's a path there
to one of the seven spots in the post
season we'll see with the lions
given their struggles i think i think
we'll see the catchphrase that aaron
rodgers came up with the other day it
applies particularly to the lions under
dan campbell and specifically with chris
spielman there
performing all sorts of duties but
bringing that attitude that mindset that
old school i love football you love
football let's play football attitude
that i think could be the thing that
helps turn the lines
around
all right i uh
i think that's it for today
we'll do it again tomorrow i'm going to
the beach next week i shouldn't have
said that but that's okay we have we
have security here my wife's very don't
don't tell people when we're leaving
it's okay there will be people here in
the house and we have security so i'm
not worried about that and a killer
attack dog named macy
who will be
ready to pounce on anyone who happens to
violate the perimeter of the property
with the no trespassing signs prominent
and all other various security measures
aimed at keeping people away so
regardless we'll figure out what we're
going to do next week i do know this
tomorrow we'll do it again appreciate
some of your time as always check us out
around the clock at profootballtalk.com
and have a great rest of your day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports